では よろしくお願いします
ではダンマパダの36番目の偈を今日説明いたします
スドゥッダサン スニプナン ヤッタカーマ ニパーティナン チッタン ラッケタ メダーウィ チッタン グッタン スカーワハン
という偈です まあこれもすごいあの説明は意味が単純簡単で
スドゥッダサン  ダサンっていうのは見えるということとか
醜い 醜いではなくて 見難い
発見するのはすごく難しいということなんですね
次の言葉 スニプナンっていうのは
まあ巧妙なっていうかな
あまりにも微妙で巧妙で
それから次の言葉はヤッタカーマ ニパーティナン
それはまあ長いんですけど
言葉長いんですけど 意味は簡単ですね
好きなところに落ちついてしまうということでね
ニパーティっていうのは
何かどこかに落ちる まあつけてしまうというようなことで
ヤッタカーマっていうのは好きなところに落ちてつけてしまうということで
これは何なのかというと
この心のことなんです
だから それがないとわからなくなっちゃうんです
心がスドゥッダサン なかなか発見しにくい
大変な もうややこしいもので
なかなか発見しにくいってことで
見難いもので 発見し難いもので
心がスニプナン ものすごい巧妙で
ということで それからヤッタカーマ ニパーティナン
好きなところに着いているんですね
その 3つの特色は心の特色なんです
それで次にチッタンという言葉が出てきますが
そのチッタン その心をラッケタ メダーウィ
ラッケタ 守りなさい もう守るのであるということでね
メダーウィ 智慧のある人は
智慧のある人はその心を守るものであると
次に理由を書いているんですね
チッタン グッタン よく守られた心がスカーワハン
幸福をもたらしてくれると
スカーワハ アーワハっていうのは流れてくるということで
スカっていうのは幸福ですね
で この偈でも一つ 心ってどういうものかということは言葉を変えて説明しています
ちょっとエピソードを読んでみたんですけど
何か大事なものあるのかと
えっと それから説明いたします
で 私たちの心はどういうものなのかということで
で 心の存在はこの まあいまだにこの
まあ仏教でしか言ってないところなんですね
うーん あんまり心はこういうもの
こういうものと言っているところはこのあまりありません
心理学というものはございますけど
それは心の学問ではありませんし
心はこういうものだというふうに独断的にしたものじゃないんです
宗教はあるんですけど
宗教でも心というものは扱ってないんです
ですから 魂よりややこしいでしょうね
魂とか霊魂といえば すべての宗教でね
よく知っていて それについていろいろ説明したりはする
ですから このブッダだけ
まあこのややこしいことに立ち会わせていてますからね
だからなかなかわかりにくいんですね
心あるのかないのかどうかね
魂があるのかないのかでは何聞いてるんですか
あるんでしょう あるに決まってるでしょうと堂々と言いますけど
心があるのかというと
そうみんな胸を張ってあるに決まってるんだよとは言わないんですね
だから心のことっていうのは
だから仏教っていうのはなかなかわかりにくくなっているんです
心の説明をするんだからね
しっかり知っているものの説明するならわかりますでしょう
魂の説明とかね するんだったらわかるんですけどね
だからそれを難しいというより
スドゥッダサンというのは
まあこんなもんやと 心っていうのはね
そう簡単には言えないんですよ
かなりもう発見しがたいものなんです
スニプナンっていうのは意味 2つあります
スニプナンというのは結構すごい素晴らしいという意味もありますよ
すごい洗練されているという意味もありますけど
やっぱりこの場合 すごい巧妙という意味ではいいと思いますけど
かなりうまく動いていますよ
逃げ腰も足も速いし そう簡単に捕まるということもできないし
ものすごい巧妙なんです
しかし 掴む発見しようと思ったら簡単です
ところ ちょっと弱いところもあります
ヤッタカーム・ニパーティナン
好きな何かあったらそちらにべったりついてるんですね
だから好きな餌撒いておけばそちらに引っかかりますけど
心っていうのは で 巧妙なんですけど
逃げ足も速いんですけど
やっぱり好きなところには引っかかっていると
それは心の普通の本来の特色なんですね
だから まず心があるのかないのかということはもうはっきりしないとね
説明したって意味がないでしょうしね
[no sound]仏教の世界では
それ心の存在というのは当たり前で考えているように
ものすごい当たり前とは言えない定義はしていますからね
魂なんかはもう全く相手にしてないんですね
すぐもうそんな話したら
すぐ簡単にそういうのはもう批判して潰してしまうんですね
魂について五蘊とかもうあまり語ってない
あっても誰かが変な頭の悪い誰かが宗教家が来てこういう質問をしました
それでこんな風に答えたところで
あいつは負けて逃げてしまったよぐらいの話で
で それあんまり扱ってないんで
だから仏教の世界では魂にすべて五蘊っていうのは話題にならなかったんですね
話にならないんだと それで心の存在っていうところでは
心とは何でしょうかっていうことは定義してあって
それからどのように働くものでしょうかということは徹底的に言ってはいくんですね
心 すごく膨大に学問にはなってます
経典の中でもあるのはどちらかというと心の説明で
心の上達する方法や心の向上させる方法やら
心はうまく働かない原因やら
心に現れる病のことやらね
幸福にしたらどうなるんでしょうかとか
そういう分析っていうのはずっとあるんです
他 仏教はないんです そういう心理学以外は
そういうことで アビダンマとかなんとかいうのはね
もう本七冊もありますけどね
かなり分厚くて読めるものでもないしね
もう現代我々に読んで理解できるようにあれは書き直そうと思っちゃうと
もうまあ五百冊もう千冊書いたってもできないんですよ
あれが別にテキストじゃないんですよ
この微妙に項目だけもう揃っているんだからね
本にはなりません だから一行一行二行での説明はこういうことになります
こういうことでこういうこと言ってますよとか
かなり量を書かなくちゃいけなくなるんです
結構 だから一応仏教だけ扱った課題だから
研究することやら それが全部やり終わってはいますけど
量が大きすぎて誰も知らないんですね
量が大きいんですけど
それを全部コンパクトにして残してはあるんです
一応これぐらいですよと
知っておくべきことはと
でもそれが知るためには結構時間かかるんですね
コンパクトにあるんですけど
しかし そういうアビダンマの説明やらね
心の分析はすごく嫌がる仏教の宗派もあります
宗教らしくやりましょうとね
拝んだり お祈りしたり
遊んだり よく楽しくやるのは正しいんじゃないかっていうふうな考え方もあります
こんな心育てることなんかは嫌やと
お祈りすればいいんじゃないかなというふうな考え方も当然あるし
これ人間というのは昔からね
宗教っていうのはお祈りするだけの世界でということでね
だから他宗教から仏教は宗教扱いされない
それでなんか立場がないんだからね
もう同等で扱ってくれないんだから
私たちもではじゃあ宗教になりましょうということで
お祈りすることになっちゃうんです
それから現代 この解剖学やらね
肉体研究っていうのはもうそれなりに進んでいて
まあほとんど終わっていると
終わるところまでは行ってるんですけど
あと少々ぐらいで 肉体っていうのはもう単純でわかりやすくて
もう何のこともない細胞があって
もう何とかって何とかって
それは動いてるだけのこと
外から酸素やら何か影響受けたりしてね
それは単純な細胞の研究っていうのは
もうもう百年 百年いろいろ頑張って
膨大なお金かかって もうなんとかまあ進んでいて
まあそれでまあ 何でしたっけ
DNA って何ぞやとかね
それは分解して終わっちゃえばもう終わりなんです
ゲノムの研究解読して終わっちゃえば
まあそれもほぼ終わってるんですけど
金くれなきゃ出してくれないということで
そう簡単に人が幸せになったら困るということではあまり発表しない
全部隠しておくんです DNA
の研究が発展すれば 病気治すことやら薬作ることやらね
そういうふうに簡単に簡単単純にできるようになるんですよ
もう高校生にもできるぐらいのテクニックでできるんですよ
だからこれ知ったら困りますよ
あちこちみんなもう簡単にがん治したりしちゃうとね
困るでしょ あの遺伝子改変っていうのは
まあ科学の世界では一番単純なことになってますからね
しかし その法則を発見するのは結構もう骨がいる必要仕事で大量にあるんだからね
この遺伝子はこの働きするんだよっていうことははっきり出してもらうっていうことは
もうもうなんかね 海岸に行って自分が決めてる何か砂一つ探すような感じで
なかなか難しいっていうことになっているんですけどね
それで心の発見ではなくて
体のことっていうのはもうとっくにわかっているし
それでそういう世界でいうのは心っていうのはないんだと
ただ脳の働きだと ということで
心は否定されているんですね
でも心がないんだという
そういうすごい立派な先生方は魂はあるとは信じています
で そこら辺 その推論理屈っていうのは
私 ちょっと仏教徒だからわからないんですね
仏教では魂のことを教えてくれてないんだからね
魂だってなんで心がないのかと
そういうことをまとめて考えると
やっぱり心っていうのはもう発見しにくいほど大変難しいことになってます
で それ心はあるのかないのかっていう問題があるのは人間になんですね
別に観察しないんだからね
だからそれは単純に私はいつでも説明しますけど
いつでも私はそれを同じことを言ってるんですね
生きてるということは何やとか見れば
それが心ということであると
でも考えてくれないんですよ
なんでしょうかね 単純でしょ
生きてる その機能っていうのは心だよと
すごく難しいみたいですね
そうすると私はいろいろ例えも出すんですよ
例えばこの建物も物体で
私も物体で同じではないかと
言った途端 頭の中で何言ってるんですかこのバカと思っちゃうでしょ
自分がすごい尊い建物はそんなものじゃないんだと思って
だからこれ理解するために言うんだから
そういうふうにも考えてもらわないと
このポイントがわからないんですよ
[背景音楽]建物は物体というところまでは理解する
体が物体と言った途端
わからないな この人の話はと
屁理屈ばっかり言ってるんだからというもう反応を出すんです
口で言ってなくたっても全部読んでいるんだから
心は 逃げませんよ あまりにも攻撃的に言っちゃうと指をさして言うんです
あんたこう考えてるんではないかとか
だからそれは私にどうすることもできない
だから体の物体 物質 物体であると
はっきりと科学的に客観的に置いておけば
その時に限って科学は嫌だと言うんでしょ
面白いことに それ以外はもう科学こそもう戦治戦のやと言い張っていて
じゃあ科学的に体見てください
ただの物体でしょうと
言うと そんな科学知ってるわけじゃないんだよと
その時また態度取っちゃうんですね
だからこれが見事に巧妙に逃げて逃げて馬鹿を守ることなんです
何言っても巧妙に逃げるんです
で 巧妙だと思ってるだけでね
仏教から見れば笑っちゃうだけで
別にもう そんなこと知ってるんだからね
もう絶対理解しないという態度取ってるんだと
でも言ってる本人はすごくもうするがすごく言ったと思っちゃうんですね
何を説明しようしたっても
科学者のもうあのちんぷんかんぷんのだらだらしている
はっきり決まってない学説は全部平気で出す
ほとんど正しくないのに
これ食っちゃえばコレステロール減るんだぞというと
途端もう食いまくっちゃうでしょうし
でもその発見した人もはっきりわかってないんですよ
一応こういうデータが出たんだよというぐらいの話で
本人は一応言うんです
だからこれこそということではありませんと
まだまだわからないこといっぱいあるんだと
なのにそれにもすぐ乗ってしまって
いろんなことやってるんですけど
そんなに科学はよろしければ
では体が物体ではないかと言ったとたん
もう え？何ですかね それはと
わからないねとかね それで体っていうのは
建物みたいに このゴミ箱みたいに
どんなそこら辺にあるどんな物体とも同じく
ただの物体 物質だと もしいつかわかっていただければ
まあ一億  三億年ぐらいかかってもいいんですけど
いつかわかっていただければ
まあそれから心の研究はできるんです
その時点から そこで物体ですけど
まるっきり同一でない
ね あのところら辺に捨てられてる丸太があって
自分の体も結局丸太とほとんど似ているでしょう
まあこの枝二つと切ってしまえば丸太だから
まあ木みたいな この本当に丁寧な丸くはないんだ
これどうせ性格悪いんだからね
まあそれはしょうがないんですけど
まあ木はすごいしっかりしてるんだから
丸太でも本当に丸いんですけどね
で 一応似てますけどね
しかし 普通のね まあどこかに切って捨ててる丸太と自分の体と比べてみると
まあ違うところはいろいろ見つかるんですよ
その違うところ見つかって比べて違うところだけポイントはピンポイントすればいいんです
それで心の発見はできると思います
で  まあ物質的な違うところはね
まあそんなに難しくはないし
で 木の物質的なものも体の物質もそれなりに少々違うんであって
でも基本的にはほとんど同じ
石と自分と比べてみると
まあ石はどんな成分でできているのか
自分がどんな成分でできているのかと言えば
まあそこら辺は少々違うものも見つかりますからね
どちらにしたっても この世の中にある物質でしょうしね
で ただ合成がちょっと変わってるだけのことです
それはそんなに難しいことじゃない
一番大きい違いは 建物が生きてないし
私が生きている そこで私と建物と何が違うかというと
科学的に何が違うかというと
その違うところに心と仏教は言うんです
それは科学的でなければいけません
建物に目がないんだとかね
そんなのはもうくだらん
そういう差は 服は着てないんではないかとかね
そういう差ではないんですよ
もっと微妙な差で 建物は生き物ではありません
自分という物体は生き物ですね
生きている 生きているという機能が心という機能なんです
その中で仏教は微妙に 2つに分析していますよ
生き物という働きにも 2種類の働きがあります
植物としての働きと生命としての働きという
そんな話に行ったっても意味がない
心はなんせあと単純に発見できんだから
そこまでは説明できない
それ説明しないんだだからみんな植物と命ごちゃにしますけど
仏教の先生ごちゃにはしません
はい で それで建物が外の世界にも反応しない
と言ったっても 2種類あります
建物も外の世界にも反応する
しかし 私の反応とは違うんです
私が 2つの反応する 建物は一つだけしか反応しない
例えば何かぶつけたら建物には傷つくんですよ
それ俺反応ですよ 自分の体に何かぶつけたら傷つくんですよ
だからそれだけは似ています
でも自分に何かぶつけたら
私は建物と違う別の反応もする
傷つくだけではなくて
それが心の働きなんです
それってものすごい難しいかもしれませんだけど
この 2番目の反応は でもリスト言いますからね
覚えておいてください
自分の体に何かぶつけたら痛いんですよ
建物は痛いと反応はしない
痛みっていうのは そうするとそこを我々は心と呼ぶんです
そこで痛いだけでは終わらない
それからずっとこの物体が嫌な気分で
グズグズグズグズと文句言いながら
もうキリがない 反応の連続は
怒ったり 感情を出したり
泣いたり 泣くことも怒りなんです
ぶつけた人に相手に攻撃することも怒りなんです
で 気分悪くなったりとかね
あるいはすごく怖くなったり
不安になったり 必死にいろんな反応する
そういうのを建物はしません
大騒ぎしたり それで病院に走ったり
そこでそちらではすぐ手当てしてくれなかったら
それにまた怒鳴ったり
怒ったり  [背景音楽]それからもういろいろそれに損害賠償やらいろんなものを要求したり
そう ものすごく終わりなくもう連続していくんですよ
それには別に物質的な説明はないんです
例えばもう玉一つね もう転がしちゃえば
その自分が入れたエネルギーで転げて転げて転げて
地球の引力もありますけど
それぐらい合わせたところで
まあここまでやっていうことははっきりするんですよ
いくら転げたっても それから永久的に無限大に反応していくということはないんでしょ？例えば石一つ空に投げてみてください
自分が石に入れた力っていうのは分かっているんだから
どれぐらい高く登るか
そんなのもう知ったもんでしょうに
そこでそれはある決まったもう決まってる時間で落ちるでしょ
まあすごい同じ時間でね
上に上がるために取った時間とそこから地面に落ちる時間というのは見事に同じで
別に誰も測ったことはないんですけど
あれは数学的に計算すると同じなんです
もしかすると違うかもしれませんだけどね
まあそういう証明できないものでも
事実やら科学で言ってるんだからしょうがないんです
必ずしもそうやって投げたものは上ゼロにスピードゼロになるまで取った時間とゼロから地面に降る時間はぴったし同じだというふうに言いますけどね
あんた調べたんでしょうかと
厳密には手の高さの分だけ違います
人間が立っている上に投げたら
まあまあ それはあれ それは分かってますからね
それは一応あれできますけどね
まあそれ研究すると 真空管の中でね
まあまあ機械で出して
また落ちる時間ということを測りますけども
そういうものは精密に測るということはね
難しいし まあそんなのはどうでもいいんですけど
そういう単純なことでも
もう科学はそれぐらいアバウトでうまくいってますよ
仏教だけでアバウトでいかないのは精密でないと
科学の世界はほとんどもうアバウト
はい それでこの建物に石がぶつけたら
建物にちょっとした傷つく
それでも物理的に まあそれで終わったということになる
反応一つの刺激に一つの反応出して終わっちゃったんですよ
自分の体も同じなんですけど
何かぶつけたらちょっと傷ついてそれで終わるはずなんですけど
終わらないんでしょ ずっと連続してつなげるんですね
嫌になって痛くなったっても
痛みはある時期で消えますけど
でもそれからもそれからもそれからも
またもう続けて続けて続けていく
それって何よと 何ですかね
それが 何と言えばいいんですかね
自分の体に石がぶつけたら傷ついただけ
それからもうすごい気分が悪くなるわ
痛くなるわ もう気持ち悪くなるわ
もうごちゃごちゃごちゃ怒ったり文句言ったりするわ
喧嘩しようとするわ あるいは震えて怯えて逃げようとするわ
病院まで走るわ 大騒ぎするわ
訴えたりもするわ それがずっとそれを覚えておいて
もしその時すごく怯えたならば
その怯えということで精神的にイかれてしまうわ
それからやがて自信がなくなって
どこまで続くか分からないんですよ
そんなに巨大な働きあるのに
それはうまく否定するでしょ
心はないんだと それが素晴らしい賢いところですよ
人間様の 明らかに違うなのに
その働きっていうのは見てみればわかるでしょ
法則的だから 誰にしたっても
石がぶつけたら痛いっていうのは法則ですからね
快感というのはありえないんです
ですから そちらもすごい丁寧な法則があって
その法則の違うところは限りなく変わって変化して
この連鎖反応っていうのは無限大
もうなんとか強引にどこかで止まってもらわない限りは
無限大に気持ちが変わっていくんです
我々はずーっと生まれてから
もうもう秒の秒の億分も止まることなくそれを感じているんですよ
この感情の強烈なこの連鎖反応
思考の強烈な連鎖反応
そんなのはお医者さんが脳の反応だとずいぶん簡単に説明したがっているんです
そういうふうなことをできるかと
まあどうせ皆様のことを医者とはいえ
科学者はね まあネズミ程度にしか考えてないんだからね
まあいいんですけどね
でも私からあまりもそんなにそんなぐらいの子供の研究じゃないんだと
もうそんなことはね ちょっとちょっとこの脳をいじってみたら反応したんだぞとかね
それで終わらないんですよ
脳細胞にちょっと電気ショック入れたら人が喋り出したと
あ なるほど こちらに電気入ったら人は喋るんだとかね
だから喋るっていうことは
このちょっとした電気的なものやとかね
はい 終わったと ここらへんいじったら人は笑っちゃいます
ここら辺でもうそこの感情をコントロールしているんだと
ここら辺に電気ショック入れたら
人にいろんなものが見えてくるんだと
それで終わってますよ
それで堂々と言うんですよ
脳の研究は全部終わってるんだと
それしかやってないんですけど
だからこのそれは専門家が我々医学本読まないんだから
素人に向かって胸張って言うんですよ
素人は資料を調べてみればそれしかないという
面白いんです それしかやった研究はないんです
科学的には まあそれであの私たち人間として
自分の自分の気持ちで直接的に実験してみると
建物の石がぶつかる 自分の体にも石がぶつかる
例えば ある人が建物めがけてものすごい勢いでもう石を投げる
同じく自分にも投げる
でも建物は物体として出す反応と自分も物体なのに出す反応は明らかに違う
キスするケガするところまでは同じ
等しい 物理的に同じ だからこちらにこれは対応という
何て言いますか レジスタンス
いわゆるまあ どれぐらい受けられるか
そのエネルギーを吸収できるかというところで
そこで引き算すれば 残りは壊れるんです
建物の場合もやっぱり衝撃をどこまで耐えられるかということがあって
この耐えられるレベルを超えた部分が壊れてしまうんです
体と建物は同じ その物理学的には 10
キロの我々は 耐えられるんだったら建物は傷つかない
この体も十キロぐらいの衝撃だったら大丈夫だったら傷つきません
まだ構造上のいろいろありますけど
まあまあ体はグニャグニャボヤンボヤだからね
まあ建物は早く傷つくんですけど
こちらはもうちょっと耐えれます
もう耐えることはできますけどね
体は で それがそれまではまあ一応私なら分かります
しかし 私がもっとすごい違う反応する
痛がる 痛くてたまらん
痛みはじーっと進んでいく
とにかくあの傷跡が治るまで痛い
もう原因も全部終わっているのに
痛みはだけは次から次へと次から次へと生まれて生まれていく
それから気持ち悪くなるでしょうに
相手に対してすっごく怒ったりするでしょうに
それもなかなか消えません
いっそそれを忘れるかというと
これはわからない それで石を殴った人に対して必ず怒るということじゃない
仏教心理学では怒るんだということに決まってますけど
しかし 人間の感覚から見れば
ある人はカンカン怒る
ある人は石を投げた人を見たら
あれは怖いと思うと言って怯えたり震えたりする
逃げようとする可能性もあるでしょうね
そこで逃げた人をあんた怒ったんでは怒るところじゃ
怖くて怖くて私は逃げましたよと
あんたに怒ることできない臆病者だと周りがからかっちゃうでしょ
でも仏教はそれどちらでも怒りというものであると
質的には怒りということで説明しますけど
でも我々俗世間から見れば
あの人は勇気を出して怒って殴り返したと
でもこいつは腰抜けて逃げちゃったと
いうふうに我々俗世間では分析します
だから感情二つだよと反応は
でも二つじゃないんです
どちらでも怒りですが
怒りでいったっても やっぱり現象になる場合は形が変わっていく
それにまた原因がある
なんでそうなるのかと
なんで攻撃して行ったんですか？なんでこの人は逃げちゃったんですかとかね
それで逃げた人の中で二人がいるとしましょう
一人が逃げて 敵が出て行っちゃったら
また堂々と胸を張って普通に世界に出る
もう一人はそれからずっと臆病で自信がなくなって
精神的にどんどんどんどん堕落していく可能性もあります
たった石一個殴られたことで
だから そういう明らかに我々には建物と違う巨大な
ものすごい強烈なエネルギーが働いています
これがもう原子の核反応みたいなもんで
一旦スタートすればどこまででも連鎖反応でいくんですよ
無限に だからそれぐらい物質と比べられない
一対一じゃないんですよ
物質と心っていうのは心の方が想像を絶するエネルギーなんです
物質なんかちっぽけなエネルギーで
それぐらいあるのに 人間には心ってわからないねというんですよ
魂 魂はやっぱり大事にしなくちゃと
だから いかに人間というのは非科学的かということでね
だから私は仏教は科学的
科学的と言っても この西洋的な科学っていう意味じゃないんです
精密にやりなさいというね
ということなんです いくらかは似ているだけで
科学はもう全てアバウト論理でいっちゃいますよ
成り立ちませんよ どうしてもアバウトでないと
例えば宇宙船なんか上へ出しちゃって
それからすごく計算するでしょ
落ちる時はこれこの角度でこの角度で来てこちらに落ちますよと
でもあれもアバウトなんですよ
ここら辺に落ちるよと
あれにはスーパーコンピューターは計算していますよ
人間にはできない 精密な計算だったらね
このポイントに落ちますよというべきでしょう
そこまではできません
でもかなり計算とコンピューター発達しているんだから
前はもう何キロ範囲でしたけどね
ソ連が宇宙船飛ばせた時はね
二 三キロ 四キロ範囲で
アメリカもそうでしたし
アメリカはちょっとそこはプライドを守るために海に落としてもらうんです
そうするとソ連よりは技術は優れているんだということで
ソ連はちゃんともう普通の陸にも落ちてもらいますよ
大体二 三キロ範囲でしたからね
それは今はね あの 随分短くなっちゃって
スペースシャトルになったところで
普通の飛行機のように決まってる場所に着陸はできる
で そうやってじわじわと発展していきますけど
やっぱりそこに至っても
やっぱりそこの場合でもアバウトはいっぱいありますよ
滑走路はもう倍長いしね
必要な距離よりは 例えば滑走路のところで木一本
建物一本もないでしょうに
あれはアバウトのためなんです
ちょっと滑ったっても
まあ一応大丈夫になるようにと
はい まあとにかくこのまあ心というものが
まあそういう話であるとした方がいいんじゃないかなと
あのミスティカル 神秘的なものではありません
我々は体より何を経験しているのかというと
心を経験しているんですよ
心で見て 心で喋って 心で呼吸して
心で味わって 心で考えて
心で感情を出して もう心で悩んで
心で喜んでやってるんだから生きてることなんですよ
だから生きていながら生きてることは知らないというと
ね おかしいとは思いますけど
生き物でありながら生きるっていうことは知らないと
あんた生き物？あ ほら
びっくりしました ほんと？初めて聞いたとかね
そんなもんじゃないと思いますけど
ですから この心っていうのは強烈なエネルギーで
問題はもういくらかそこまでは
あの いくらか あの 論理的に考えるんだったら
やっぱり心があるんだよと
石を投げられただけでも
もう心は明確に見えるでしょうに
十年 二十年 あるいは一生でもこの連鎖反応は起こるでしょうに
それぐらいの心でことで心の存在はわかります
が 心の働きって本当にどういうことかと研究することは
これが至難の業なんです
[背景音楽]あるというぐらいでも発見するのは難しいんだからね
こんなに大胆にあるのに
どこかに山に珍しい動物がいるんだぞと言ったら
まあそれでしょうかとものすごい苦労すると
ああやっぱりいるんだっていうぐらいわかりますけど
その動物の生態やら生き方やらあれこれとかね
全て発見するためにはもう大変難しいんですよ
そういうことで 心はまああることはあるんですけど
つぶったさ ものすごく発見し難いしがたいし
研究しがたいものになっているんです
[背景音楽]